[Music]
Dora the Explorer was a part of most of
our childhoods and it helped us learn
our first few Spanish words the show is
named is one of the most popular kids
cartoons of all time and today we'll
show you what these characters would
look like in real life stay tuned to the
end to see ridiculously adorable
real-life Dora hey guys check out our
new member of the family toy hub toy hub
is the ultimate place for kids to get
their daily dose of crunchy slime
squishy slimes sticky slime play-doh
color learning and so much more we have
lots of fun with the most awesome toys
and amazing stories for kids make sure
to show it to all the kids in your
family and while you're there make sure
to subscribe and hit that like button at
toy hub it's playtime don't forget to
like this video and subscribe to our
Channel today we're checking out ten
Dora the Explorer characters in real
life let's start with Dora's best friend
and one of the cutest characters on the
show this little monkey gets easily
discouraged but he also loves to learn
just like any monkey out there he loves
bananas boots is best known for loving
just about everything that is and he's
definitely a heartwarming character
we'll get ready because your heart is
about to jump from joy when you see
boots in real life sure he's a monkey
but we found the collection of these
ridiculously cute monkeys that will
hopefully brighten your day check out
this little cutie in a boots costume if
that didn't impress you wait until you
see these real-life monkeys so cute
speaking of monkeys did you know that
the fastest primate on earth Award
belongs to a monkey they're called
pattice and they are as fast as your
regular racehorse which is about 35
miles per hour pretty impressive right
but if you want an animal that's just as
cute as Dora's BFF you can get that too
we can't get over all of these cute
monkeys the question is
are they any cuter than Dora's monkey
boots
Swiper as the main antagonist of the
show
Swiper definitely brings more to the
table than just his character you've
probably heard of the Swiper no swiping
meme but do you know it actually comes
from Dora the Explorer the Swiper no
swiping
saying belongs to Dora Swiper the Sly
Fox that he is always tries to swipe
objects that Dora and Boots need to
reach their destination they have to say
Swiper no swiping
three times for him to leave them alone
but he's not an actual villain as he's
shown its good side many times
throughout the show
Swiper belongs to a red fox species and
here's a photo of what they look like in
real life they look beautiful don't they
they're much fiercer than Swiper but
they do actually live practically
anywhere in the world
Swiper also has the same bushy tail as
red foxes they use their fluffy tail to
keep themselves warm during the winter
but it also comes in handy when it comes
to communicating with other foxes and
since Swiper is cute here are some of
the cutest pictures of red foxes we
managed to find and don't forget this
important message Swiper no swiping
backpack although it's an object
backpack is still an important character
in Dora the Explorer this object is a
special helper and she loves to solve
problems she's appeared on every single
episode and she always managed to save
Dora if you love Dora as a child we bet
you actually had a Dora backpack it
probably looked something like this and
had a picture of Dora the Explorer
characters this is a real-life version
of Dora's special helper and we love it
backpacks in general have a pretty
interesting history the modern version
of the backpack you know and use in
school today
is actually just 44 years old the first
backpack with the zipper was invented in
1938 by the Jerry outdoors brand since
then
many modern backpacks came about but we
love that Dora can go on her adventures
using just a small and simple purple
backpack but we have to admit we'd love
to have a backpack that could actually
talk daizy marquez daisy marquez is a
minor character but she still appears in
many Dora the Explorer episodes daizy
turned 15 in October 2004 and she even
had an episode dedicated to her
quincenera quincenera comes from Latin
America's culture and it's a celebration
of a girl turning 15 well we found her
look-alike and she'd only be a couple of
years older than Daisy do you remember
America Ferrera this sassy actress
became best known for her roles as
Carmen in Sisterhood of the Traveling
Pants series and Betty in Ugly Betty
but doesn't she totally look like a
real-life version of Daisy you'll never
believe the hard work it takes to
produce a single episode of dora the
team consists of 300 people and it can
take a whole year to produce a single
episode before in episode airs the team
gets 75 lucky preschoolers to review it
and give their opinions no wonder why
Dora is such a hit it's child approved
we wonder what they think of our choice
for the Daisy Marquez look-alike Tico
and who can forget about Tico one of the
most colorful squirrels we have ever
seen
Tico's body has a unique dark purple
color which is nothing like we've ever
seen on a regular squirrel plus he
speaks totally fluent Spanish which
we're extremely jealous of he appears in
most episodes and is definitely a
favorite character
you can't deny that's definitely
adorable and while we're sure you've
seen squirrels in real life before here
are some extra cute ones to make your
day and yes that squirrel is wearing a
hat and seems to be playing a trumpet
just imagine these cuties wearing Tico's
colorful outfit speaking of squirrels
here's a reason why you should pay more
attention to them as they're quite
special
did you know they sometimes pretend
they're burying their food to distract
their
hookers once they see that their trick
was successful they move on and actually
bury their stash somewhere where no one
is looking although we have to say we'd
love to see actual squirrels operate a
vehicle the way Tico does Benny next is
Benny the bull and no we don't mean this
Benny the bull mascot you might know
from the Chicago Bulls team this Benny
is blue totally lovable and ridiculously
clumsy he's one of those characters you
can't help but love we adore him for his
clumsiness and innocence
Benny's an actual proof that Bulls
aren't as scary as we think they are in
fact we bet you'd love to see a
real-life bull we scoured the internet
for some of the best real-life versions
of Benny and here are the cutest Bulls
we managed to find see they're not that
scary most people think that the color
red makes Bulls angry but Bulls actually
can't see the red color in the first
place as they're colorblind what does
make them angry is the movement of the
Cape as they wave it around so don't
worry if you're wearing any red around a
bull as there's a good chance nothing
will happen to you bulls are also pretty
rare in herds and you can only spot a
single bull in an average herd of 30
cows and you know what's even rarer the
adorable Benny from Dora the Explorer
one of the most unique bull characters
we've ever seen hands up if you love
Benny the bull Diego and of course we
also have to mention Diego Marquez
Dora's cousin and Daisy's little brother
Diego is totally fearless and very
athletic we love him for his thirst for
knowledge and love for all animals
unlike other characters on the show
Diego uses a lot of gadgets to solve
problems and he's always able to come up
with a solution he has brown hair and is
almost always seen wearing a vest
check out this perfect real-life version
of Diego it's a costume you're able to
buy and we managed to find an unusual
celebrity who decided to come
play in the adult version of the Diego
costume in 2009 cash Warren and Jessica
Alba were spotted dressed as Diego and
Dora the Explorer for Halloween and
check out these real-life Diego and Dora
characters did you know that he was
voiced by four actors on the show the
character was voiced by Philippe Deepa
Jake TOS in Brandon Zambrano and
Nicholas can - they all definitely look
just as cute as the tech-savvy Diego
Diego also has his own spin-off show
called Go Diego Go that was just as
popular as Dora the Explorer however we
have to say we do love seeing Dora and
Diego interact with each other and solve
problems Mac just like backpack we know
map is an object but he's also an
important character in the show and we
felt like he deserved his time to shine
map is there to help Dora and Boots
figure out where they need to go and you
can find him in every single episode of
the show this is what a real-life
version of map would look like except
you have to admit that map is actually
much cuter we love his large eyes map
also appeared on Diego's spin-off show
Go Diego Go he is voiced by mark whiner
who was actually best known for his Dora
the Explorer projects you can't deny
that this show wouldn't be the same
without this helpful character did you
know that mapping dates back to more
than 5,000 years ago of course the
actual map developed more as people got
a chance to explore the world but maps
were made of very simple sketches that
simply helped people get from point A to
point B check out this interesting
version of the world map that dates back
to 1482 it was created by Ptolemy a
geographer and astronomer who lived in
Roman Egypt it's hard to believe we
managed to explore so much of our world
since then can you imagine our world
without maps we bet dora the explorer'
would definitely look different Explorer
stars and you know we can't forget about
the Explorer stars they travel with Dora
as she goes on her exploring adventure
and they each come with unique abilities
that help Dora along the way we've seen
more than 30 Explorer star characters on
the show but some of our favorites are
the funny star cowgirl star and movie
star here are some of the cutest
real-life star costumes we managed to
find of course an actual star looks
slightly different than this and since
Dora the Explorer teaches us so much
about this world we thought we'd give
you a quick trivial lesson on the outer
space some stars are brighter than the
others because of their proximity to the
earth and the energy they're putting out
if the star has a huge mass their life
cycle will be shorter this is what a
dying star would look like it began
shedding its layer 14,000 years ago and
it's now in its final phase becoming
smaller and producing more and more heat
we hope our short trivia was just as
good as Dora's lessons Dora Dora is
definitely one of the most recognized
characters out there her last name is
Marquez and she's the main character
who's appeared in every single series as
well as a few spin-off versions although
she's a tomboy Dora is kind-hearted and
loves to help just about everyone she's
on good terms with all characters
including Swiper which says a lot about
her kind spirit her short brown hair
pink shirt orange shorts and her
backpack makers stand out from the rest
here are some of the cutest real-life
Dora look-alikes we managed to find
adorable aren't they
this proves that Dora really is suitable
for all ages and we bet that many
parents love this show no wonder it's
ranked as the number one children's
television program it really taught kids
to embrace modern technology it taught
them a new language and highlighted
Latin American culture but did you know
that Dora only teaches kids Spanish in
the United States New Zealand Canada
Australia and Ireland in other countries
the show helps children learn English
and even though it ended in 2015 we bet
that Dora will remain one of the most
popular kids shows ever
and that's it for ten dora the explorer'
characters in real life for more videos
like this one check out 10 Teen Titans
go characters in real life see you next
time
[Music]